la diaspora descendre documentaire
réalisé par William Carrel l'auteur
d'une quinzaine de films consacrés à la
Shoah il a donc choisi ici
d'entrecroiser les nombreux témoignages
dont ils disposent aux côtés des
victimes mais aussi des bourreaux du
génocide pour retracer le processus
d'extermination des Juifs européens mis
en œuvre par les nazis un génocide qui
fera quelques six millions de morts mais
dont le monde ne mesurera réellement
l'ampleur que bien des années plus tard
pourquoi nous allons poser la question à
notre invité présent maintenant sur ce
plateau de débat doc tal Brugmann
bienvenue bonjour vous êtes historiens
spécialiste de la Shoah et de
l'antisémitisme en France et auteur
entre autres de ce livre les 100 mots de
la Shoah publiée au presse
universitaires de France ça n'ouvrage
que vous avez d'ailleurs coécrit avec
Christophe tarikon première question
nous venons de voir ce film ensemble à
vos yeux quelle est la principale force
la principale originalité de ce
documentaire de William Carrel que nous
venons de voir il y en a plusieurs je
trouve d'abord le fait alors on a que
des voix off de témoins victimes
bourreau ou ou de ce que raoulilah a
appelé les by standers mais qui est un
ensemble général où on a des résistants
des habitants de tel ou tel endroit et
déjà on a aucun commentaire donc c'est
vraiment brut et c'est très très
finement l'autre élément c'est que ça
renvoie des démarches qui ont déjà été
réalisées précédemment n'ont pas que
c'est la même chose mais c'est un peu
dans la même veine les travaux de
Charles Friedlander le grand historien
israélo-américain de la Shoah qui a
écrit deux énormes
volume d'analyse sur l'histoire de la
choix de 33 à 45 qui s'appuient
énormément sur les témoignages justement
croisés de victimes de bourreau ou de
personnes qui sont là pendant que c'est
de déroulent l'événement puis un autre
documentaire qui a une quarantaine
d'années qui a été fait par le
réalisateur à linge Aubert qui s'appelle
Auschwitz l'album de la mémoire et où on
entend justement les voix de 4 escapés
qui témoignent en s'appuyant uniquement
sur des photos qui ont été prises à
auschwitt quel est l'intérêt lorsqu'on
parle de la Shoah de croiser justement
les témoignages des victimes et des
bourreaux ça donne à vouloir plusieurs
choses d'abord que les bourreaux savent
énormément de choses pris
individuellement et là William Cavell se
balade sur toute la hiérarchie
de l'État nazi voire même des
collaborateurs à travers l'Europe du
Maréchal Pétain à Céline etc etc donc on
peut voir le point de vue entre
guillemets de chacun et le niveau de
connaissance qu'on les différents
acteurs de la persécution et de
l'assassinat et il suffit de voir par
exemple dans le documentaire il y a il y
a une lettre d'un officier de la
Wehrmacht qui explique l'ampleur du
crime qui est commis et qui sera porté
enfin une tâche sur l'histoire allemande
à tout jamais donc on voit qu'on a des
hommes qui sont a priori à l'écart de
l'assassinat qui est réalisé par les SS
et d'autres organisations spéciales là
on a un membre de la Wehrmacht et il
sait exactement de quoi il en retourne
et même chose quand on regarde du côté
des victimes on voit que leur
perspective et leur degré de
connaissance est très variable et que
leur compréhension de ce face à quoi ils
sont confrontés là aussi très variables
et d'un coup ça permet aussi d'aller
plus loin que ce qu'ils disent avec ce
que nous on connaît on va simplement
passer un panneau nous indiquant le
nombre de Juifs décédés par camp
d'extermination ou centre de mise à mort
je crois que c'est une expression que
vous préférez à celle de camps
d'extermination en tout cas six ans
avait été reconnu comme ayant été des
camps d'extermination quand nazi bien
entendu regardez ces chiffres 1 dans
l'ordre décroissant avec un million de
morts à Auschwitz Birkenau triblinka
environ 925000 Belzec environ 434
000 morts shelmo entre 156 et 172000
morts Sobibor environ 167.000 morts et
Matt danak environ 60 000 morts Juifs là
il y a une sur ce panneau c'est entre 60
et 80000 décédés mais 60000 victimes
spécifiquement juives que sont devenus
les rescapés de ces camps
d'extermination notamment
ont-ils souhaité témoigner pouvait-il
seulement le faire après le traumatisme
que cela représentait pour eux alors
c'est une immense question tout d'abord
il faut vraiment insister sur une chose
d'une part dans ce que vous avez
mentionné à l'instant en termes de bilan
il y a Auschwitz et puis les autres
lieux d'assassinat Auschwitz qui a la
particularité d'être à la fois un centre
de mise à mort et un camp de
concentration va avoir la particularité
de voir un nombre très élevé par rapport
aux autres lieux de rescapés juifs qui
ont été envoyés dans le système
concentrationnaire ce qui va les
épargner temporairement il suffit de
citer quelques noms Primo Levi Simone
Veil par exemple ou imbrictertech pour
prendre des grandes figures connues en
Europe sont des rescapés du camp de
concentration de Auschwitz en revanche
le centre de mise à morte à Auschwitz là
où les Juifs qui arrivent sont
immédiatement envoyés à l'exception d'un
faible nombre c'est quasiment 900 000
victimes qui ont été assassinés dès les
premières heures de leur arrivée et
c'est là justement à la sortie
exactement sur la voie de chemin de fer
on tout le monde a ses images en tête
ses récits et Xavier aussi dans ce
documentaire et envoyer vers les
chambres à Diaz et justement les autres
sites ressemblent à ça c'est à dire que
les victimes arrivent sur le site des
centres du train et là il y a pas de
sélection autrement dit 100% de chaque
convoi et immédiatement détruit ce qui
fait que le nombre de rescapés de ces
lieux et ridiculement faible
par exemple il y a à la fin de la guerre
de rescapés identifié même chose pour un
site comme Belzec d'autres sites comme
ceibor est très Milica vont voir
quelques dizaines de rescapés pour des
raisons très simples il y a eu des
révoltes qui vont réussir mais on parle
d'une trentaine à une cinquantaine de
rescapés des gens qui ont réussi à
s'enfuir et à survivre tout au long de
la guerre pour traiter on sait qu'il y a
une centaine de gens qui ont réussi à
fuir lors de la révolte une partie va
être reprise par les SS ou tuer y
compris par des populations locales donc
extrêmement peu de rescapés ce qui
expliquerait le peu témoignage
exactement après la libération des camps
mais justement c'est là où il y a un
phénomène encore plus important c'est
que certains de ces évadés vont
témoigner très tôt des 43-44 et par
exemple aux États-Unis il y a un
témoignage d'un rescapé de tradingka qui
est publié dès 1944 donc les témoignages
commencent à atteindre une sphère au
sein de l'opinion publique très tôt même
avant la fin de la guerre évidemment à
fortiori après la libération des quand
des grands nombres de rescapés y compris
Juifs vont être libérés des camps de
concentration on va avoir des
témoignages qui vont commencer à être
publiés beaucoup de Juifs de REP
orientales après la guerre environ
332000 choisissent l'exil dans le tout
nouvel État d'Israël créé en 1947 on
aurait pu penser que cela allait
contribuer à libérer la parole pas
vraiment voir pas du tout et là par
exemple un historien israélien Tom
seghev avait écrit une étude et une
vingtaine d'années sur le sujet qui
s'appelle le septième million qui
justement s'intéresse à ce point très
particulier parce que les créateurs de
l'État d'Israël essaie de créer non plus
un homme juif entendu avec des
guillemets soumis à l'antisémitisme et
quelqu'un qui serait totalement délié de
la violence que les Juifs ont connu en
Europe pendant des siècles or quand
c'est rescapés arrivent ils arrivent
dans une société qui se construit par
opposition à ce juif tel qu'il a été
modelé par l'antisémitisme et donc quand
ils arrivent ils sont vus comme des
victimes dans un pays nouveau qui se
veut un pays de pionniers de combattants
puisque Israël né dans la guerre avec
les États arabes alentours et donc leur
voix est totalement dissonante par
rapport au projet politique de créer un
État qui tourne le dos à se passer
violent qu'on subit les Juifs alors vous
avez évoqué le sujet tout à l'heure mais
c'est vrai que la spécificité du
génocide juif n'a pas été prise en
compte par les alliés notamment au
fameux procès l'Union Humbert alors
pourquoi alors il y a la question est
mineurement importante et c'est là où il
y a plusieurs choses à prendre en compte
d'abord effectivement
la spécificité n'est pas prise en compte
mais elle est évoquée et notamment du
côté de la partie soviétique on va avoir
plusieurs témoins juives qui vont
témoigner de la Shoah y compris un évadé
très blink sauf que et en plus là c'est
un élément on va dire juridique mais qui
a toute son importance au moment où
s'ouvre le procès de Nuremberg
le crime de génocide n'est pas encore
défini juridiquement alors le terme est
évoqué par le procureur général Jackson
mais sa figure pas dans les chefs
d'incubation il va falloir attendre la
fin des années 40 pour que le crime de
génocide devienne un instrument de la
justice internationale donc il y a ce
premier élément et en plus nurember
c'est vraiment le procès des
responsables de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale donc pour les Alliés le sort
des Juifs ne se distingue pas
particulièrement d'autres populations
occupées il va falloir attendre un
certain temps pour que le sujet émerge
et on va voir une date charnière qui va
être le procès d'adolpheichmann à
Jérusalem en
197961 il est capturé en 60 le procès à
Lyon en 1961 et ce procès a été voulu
par David Ben Gourion comme la
souligné-annette vivorkia comme le
nuraberg du peuple juif autrement dit le
procès d'Eichmann va être le procès au
cours duquel on va juger l'histoire et
en fait le principal organisateur de la
solution finale de pas le choix et là
nous sommes en 61 autrement dit déjà 16
ans après la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale exactement donc vous voyez que
ils font un certain temps et en plus ce
qui se passe en Israël même si ça a de
quoi l'extérieur en France en Allemagne
aux États-Unis ça va pas ça va avoir son
importance mais pas une réserve danse
immédiate en Allemagne il faut attendre
le procès de Francfort quelques années
plus tard dit procès d'hauschwitt pour
voir l'Allemagne se tournait vers ce
sujet là en France il va falloir
attendre les années 70 et aux États-Unis
la fin des années 70 notamment avec la
projection de la série holocauste une
série télévisée holoco c'est
effectivement diffusée pour la première
fois aux États-Unis en 1978 de là
viendra d'ailleurs le nom holocoost les
Anglo-Saxons parlent de holocauste en
fait en Europe continental on parle de
Shoah alors il y a plusieurs termes qui
sont utilisés le terme holocauste est
utilisé dès la seconde guerre mondiale
mais du point de vue anglo-saxon pour
désigner les violences en Europe et
ensuite le sort des Juifs la série va
populariser le mot mais qui était déjà
en usage à partir de 19 78 il va se
répandre et au même moment en France
plusieurs intellectuels vont commencer à
dire que holoca pose problème de fait
puisque le terme signifie une offrande à
Dieu un sacrifice à Dieu en disant ça
pose problème il vaut mieux utiliser le
terme choix à vous l'avez dit sont les
années 70 à Stains importants pour la
construction de la mémoire de la Shoah
pourquoi les années 70 parce qu'on est
sur une génération d'après-guerre y
compris chez les historiens on a une
nouvelle lecture de ce qui s'est passé
durant cette seconde guerre mondiale
concernant les Juifs en Europe il y a
plusieurs phénomènes qui vont
s'entrecroiser d'abord les procès
successifs qui vont avoir des
éco-particuliers Eichmann le procès
d'outschwitt en Allemagne
un intérêt du public qui va croissant il
suffit de regarder notamment la
production hollywoodienne où vous avez
des grands films comme Marathon Man ou
ces garçons qui venaient du Brésil ou
alors le succès de livres comme ceux de
Simon visenthal qui qui publie les
assassins sont parmi nous chasseurs de
nazis exactement même titre que
exactement qui à ce moment-là deviennent
de plus actifs de plus en plus actifs et
de plus en plus visible donc l'opinion
publique si on reste sur le cas de la
France s'intéresse au sujet en plus en
France vous avez régulièrement des
affaires comme la faire tout vier sous
la présidence Pompidou et en même temps
il va y avoir un ressurgissement cette
fois du côté de l'ultra collaboration
sur la scène publique on va voir les
déclarations de Darty de pelpoy qui est
dans les réfugiés en Espagne Franco le
protège et qui déclare aux chevilles
Sonia Z des poux ce qui en fera
évidemment provoque un scandale et là
dessus vous allez avoir
des thèses révisionnistes arrivées sur
la place publique
c'est peut-être aussi le cas concernant
Jean-Marie Le Pen avec le Front National
qui parle d'un détail de l'histoire
concernant les chambres à gaz en fait
Jean-Marie Le Pen c'est la face la plus
visible d'un mouvement dédiationniste
qui s'affirme vraiment dans les années
70 78 le journal Le Monde par exemple va
commettre une bévue fondamentale en
publiant un courrier négationniste de
Robert Faurisson à la fin des années 70
donc Jean-Marie Le Pen ne fait que
qu'être la chambre des cours et avec un
éco-autantissant de ce mouvement là et
en réaction les rescapés d'Auschwitz en
France vont commencer à témoigner de
façon très massive
pour justement venir contrecarrer cette
parole qui a quand même un certain
comédien qui suffit de regarder dans les
années 80 il y a plusieurs émissions de
télé où on invite des négationnistes
avec en face des victimes de
l'antisémitisme 5 minutes pour les 5
minutes pour les autres et à l'arrivée
tout est imaginable aujourd'hui ou
est-ce qu'on peut encore considérer que
le négationnisme existe encore bel et
bien en Europe par exemple les
négationnisme existe toujours il est
bien ancré en France il suffit de
regarder Alain Soral ou Dieudonné mais
lui il est totalement excluant on va
dire de la sphère médiatique
traditionnelle en revanche fut la
période qu'on vit quelqu'un comme Éric
Zemmour tient des propos qui frisent le
négationnisme quand il affirme par
exemple le maréchal Pétain a sauvé les
Juifs de France ce qui est doublement ou
triplement faux le maréchal Pétain n'a
jamais sauvé le moindre juif en
l'occurrence les Juifs français en
particulier contrairement à ce qui
affirme Éric Zemmour n'ont pas été
protégé etc etc on a une non même pas
une révision de l'histoire on on a une
négation de la réalité historique mais
utilisez pour un projet politique selon
l'historien Saul Freelander vous l'avez
cité au tout début de notre entretien
l'entreprise de destruction des Juifs
d'Europe révèle relève pardon de deux
périodes les années de persécution dans
un premier temps puis les années
d'extermination qu'on a évidemment
évoqué ensemble avons-nous assisté par
la suite à des années de réparation
totalement en fait et là à nouveau tout
dépend où on se place si on reste sur
l'exemple français il faut attendre le
discours de Jacques Chirac en 1995 au
Vél' d'Hiv' 95
Chirac qui établit la responsabilité de
l'État français concernant la
déportation des Juifs de France
exactement il reconnaît et cette
reconnaissance là va ouvrir une vraiment
une nouvelle page en France qui va
permettre de se pencher sur d'autres
questions notamment la question des
spoliation qui avait été totalement
oublié à la fois par les victimes et par
l'état français non pas volontairement
mais parce que l'histoire s'est écrite
ici et qui va être réouverte on va avoir
une série et là ça va être porté à la
fois
par les gouvernements successifs Juppé
et Jospin et ensuite repris notamment
par la justice puisqu'il y a une série
de décisions qui vont faire que pendant
une vingtaine d'années on va voir l'état
au sens noble du terme se pencher sur ce
passé-là et justement essayer
d'éclaircir toutes les zones d'ombre
avec cette fameuses commissions matéoli
le Mémorial de la Shoah en France qui
est inaugurant en 2005 qui inaugurée en
2005 et donc le travail de cette fameuse
commission matteolie que vous avez
évoqué et qui commencera donc dans les
années 2000 et qui visera desdommager
ceux et celles alors justement c'est pas
tant des dommages des victimes c'est
établir ce qui s'est passé et le
résultat va être il va être estimé 2
milliards de francs n'avaient pas été
restitués et l'État français va décider
de créer une fondation la pour la
mémoire de la Shoah qui va justement
financer tout un ensemble de recherches
d'inauguration du Mémorial de la Shoah à
Paris etc et ça sera ma dernière
question tel ruthman que cherchez-vous à
prendre aujourd'hui de nouveaux sur la
Shoah pour l'historien que vous êtes
alors ça fait plus de 2000 ans qu'on
fait l'histoire de Rome ou d'Athènes
donc il y a toujours du nouveau
les grands historiens qui qui m'ont
précédé ou qui ont précédé ceux de ma
génération les
léopolyakoff raoulberg Charles
Friedlander Serge Klarsfeld ont établi
le cas de général de cette histoire là
il reste énormément de zones d'ombre de
choses à affiner de morceaux de du
puzzle à venir trouver où ces morceaux
se placent donc chaque historien apporte
à sa modeste mesure un degré de
connaissance supplémentaire et moi je
m'inscris dans ce qui a été fait
précédemment en espérant que ce que moi
je fais aura une un intérêt quelconque
sur votre travaux avec le plus grand
intérêt merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous pour cette émission des Badoc
consacrée à la mémoire de la Shoah et du
selfie le chemin était long on l'a bien
compris à travers notre entretien après
ce formidable documentaire aussi bien
sûr de de William Carrel c'est un des
grands spécialistes des films
documentaires tournés et conçus réalisés
autour de la de la Shoah vos réactions
ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc bien sûr
sur Twitter merci aussi à sel massali
qui comme à la coutumée m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission je vous donne
rendez-vous tout simplement pour un
prochain débat docs et ce sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat à
bientôt
[Musique]